ron desantis was invited to go to the
view
his team said this is brian griffin to
santa's deputy press secretary tweeted
that the florida governor had received
an invitation to be on the show they
said we would be honored this is what
they said i hope you're having a good
summer
i'm sure i'm reaching out to invite
governor ron desantis to be our special
guest on the view next season which
starts september 6th we would be honored
to have him join us in studio sometime
in the fall de santis who does not play
he's a boss he just does he's like i'm
sorry i'm not playing your game
came back and said
um
which of the blow statements from the
host of the view do you recommend our
team consider when deciding if the
interview will be a genuine pursuit of
truth or worth the time and then he
includes these comments i think he's a
fascist and a bigot sonny hostin said in
june you're just sort of calling
governor desantis a negligent homicidal
sociopath because that's what he is joy
behar said wow and he was like i'll pass
so i see this i see this and you know i
say good on him
the view
used to be a place where you used to be
able to go when barbara walters was in
charge it used to be a place where you
could go and have a real discussion you
know she
prided that show on differences of
opinion being acknowledged at the table
on a respectful discussion you can go
back and watch tape where i think there
was one episode where bill o'reilly was
on and whoopi and joy walk out and she's
like get back here yeah
but that's not what's going on anymore i
mean you saw my appearance there they
shouted me down like as misinformation
they completely set me up of course so
at this point
good on him i feel like that show needs
to decide if they if they want people to
come on who have differing views they
have to act with respect and if they're
not going to act with respect then
they're going to get answers like this
and this is what people should say sorry
not interested i'm not looking to be set
up yeah what do you think
well first of all love that show i every
day i'm one and i don't i'm actually i'm
[ __ ] that you're a big joy be hard man
yeah i love her and i first of all i
think you should have because you just
said it you should have your own spin
off and call it a different route of
different view and it's the complete
opposite of what they're doing i have
zero respect for them because it's not
like you said when barbara walters there
it everybody had a view and everybody
talked and we worked through and
whatever now it's just like like the
media they're political activists it's
just whatever the left wants them to say
they're saying and i don't respect any
of them because have you ever seen any
of them jump off and go to anybody
else's show have you ever seen any of
them anywhere else sitting there and
being interviewed never you never
because they have to be in that little
bubble they have to be in that little
room all the audience all those guests
you know they're all set up to go after
people like you anything that they say
is truth and it's gold and they get like
bill maher's audience who i know bill
maher i love because he's shifting but
those audience if you don't think or act
or respond how they respond
they shun you down and they boo your ass
yeah i just
i just feel like ron desantis is perfect
because you know yo he's not stupid he's
the real woke yeah he knows what they
were trying to do bro and the fact that
he has those links of you talk [ __ ] here
you talk to you there you want me there
like you don't you don't think that we
know the setup has happened and you know
what's sad to me is i used to be the
biggest advocate of like go into these
spaces have these conversations change
hearts and minds like you never know who
you'll reach like my experience there
for the most part was pretty good when i
worked there um i had a few days that
were odd interviewing hillary clinton it
was an odd day um there were like just
days
i felt like there was panic around what
i couldn't couldn't say on a couple of
days but for the most part i felt like i
sat down i said what i had to say and
when i left
many of the audience members were like
dad you made me think like i didn't i
didn't like you at first but you know i
thought about things in a different way
which to me was like i did a good day's
work so i am a fan generally of like get
out of your comfort zone stop preaching
to the choir
the challenge is when it's set up
when it's it's not when they don't have
an interest in an actual conversation
and they're just there to mock you to
set you up then that's just there's no
there's no advantage then to doing that
like why am i going to go to be abused
you know so i think i think it's kind of
a moment where they're going to have to
figure out who they are i don't think
he's going to be the last person that
says that do you think trump would go on
there do you think people are gone i
think trump would go on
uh
good or bad like do you think he should
have went just to get those difficult
actually you know what now i don't know
i really think they're going to have a
hard time booking
real genuine conservatives who want a
discussion yeah who aren't there just
for like that moment that i mean i went
on people say to me well why did you go
on i
i had a full pre-interview with them so
i they knew what i was we talked through
the mandates like an hour long
pre-interview so i was like i want to
have this discussion they have a big
audience i want to show people why i'm
not getting this vaccine and why there's
a whole segment of the population that's
not just going to comply like i wanted
that to be heard it was a legitimate
i show up it's like bam misinformation i
don't get to say it's like ridiculous
but i think there are good there are
people who now are seeing that it's not
an opportunity it's not an opportunity
to have a conversation or change hearts
you can't do that
with people who are trying to to to like
make a point out of you so i would tell
him not to go i would tell trump to say
i'm sorry but no thank you like if it's
going to be like this they decide to
change the way they treat people they
decide to have a respectful exchange of
ideas but isn't that one of the reasons
why people like trump because he does do
things that are going to be like whoa
like what like he's gonna take on this
challenge you know like
like to me i look at that as like that's
somebody who's not scared to get
canceled per se
um so like i don't know i think
i don't think it's even about canceling
though i think people are tired of
giving them ratings for mistreating like
i'm not going to give you the benefit of
me showing up if you're going to be
disrespectful because those are clicks
because they want that that's what it's
down to now trump could go i will say
this my disadvantage was that i was not
in person they wouldn't let me into the
studio even with a negative covet test
had i been on that set
they would have been in trouble i love
it because
and they know it they know it that's why
they didn't have me on the set they
would have been in trouble because i
don't back down i know what i'm talking
about and i was following the science
and they weren't if you like the short
clip you can catch another one here or
you can catch the full episode right
here
[Music]